[موسيقى]
احييكم وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا المساء
تقدموها لكم ميسون وايهد العنوي
دا بالعداء تجاه روسيا
الرئيس الامريكي يرد انت من تسبب بالحرب
عاده نيو ستارت النوويه تلفظ انفازها
الاخيره بين نعي روسي وتوعد امريكي وتخوف
اممي
زلزال جديد ام هز ارتداديه الزلزال الاخير
في هاتاي يحيي العلماء والمخاوف تدفع
السوريين للعوده الى بلادهم
يكشف عن مفاوضات سريه بين نتانيا هو محمود
عباس بدات قبل شهرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مناوشه بالتصريحات بين الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ونظيره الروسي الذي
اتهم الاول بتوجيه العداء الغربي نحو
الشرق والتسبب بالحرب التي تجري في
اوكرانيا اما بايدن فجاء رده من على بعد
كيلومترات من الحدود الروسيه تحديدا من
بولندا متواعدا بوتين بان اوكرانيا لن
تكون انتصارا له مشددا للوقت ذاته على
مواصله الدعم الغربي لكاف الحرب ومؤكدا
ايضا على ان الناتو لن يضعف ولن ينقسم
ابدا
[موسيقى]
كيف ما تزال صامده وتشعر بالفخر والكبرياء
والاهم انها ما تزال حره
عندما قامت روسيا بشن عملها العدائي كان
العالم قد اجتمع ليعيش اختبارا اوروبا
والناتو والولايات المتحده وكافه
الديمقراطيات استجابتنا ابتسمت بالوحده
واظهرنا مدى وحدتنا وقوتنا للعالم
[موسيقى]
الغرب صرف اكثر من 150 مليار دولار لدعم
النظام الاوكراني عسكريا وخصص 60 مليار
دولار للدول الفقيره تيار الاموال الى
الحرب مستمر الغرب يتهم روسيا لنسيان ما
فعله في العقود الماضيه الحروب التي شنها
الغرب تحت شعار الديمقراطيه تسببت في
تشريد مئات الملايين الغرب دعم الانقلاب
الدمويه في اوكرانيا ونشر الكراهيه ضد
روسيا وعليكم ان تعلموا انه كل ما زاد مدى
الاسلحه التي تصل الى اوكرانيا سنكون
مضطرين لابعاد هذا التهديد عن حدودنا
سياسيه يجريها الرئيس الامريكي بينكافا
وارسو قبل عودته الى واشنطن تتزامن مع
الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب الروسيه ضد
اوكرانيا زيارات تترافق مع اجراء القوات
الامريكيه مناورات عسكريه مشتركه على
الجانب الاخر من اوروبا
بمحاذاه الجزء الغربي من روسيا اي في
فنلندا تحديدا المناورات في منطقه لابلاند
الفنلنديه يشارك فيها ما يقرب من الف جندي
امريكي وتحاكي حربا في القطب الشمالي
المناورات ستستمر حتى السابع عشر من مارس
المقبل اما التدريبات فتقسم الى نصفين
تدريبات شامله مكثفه شمالي فنلندا وتمرين
الفايكنج المشترك في النرويج الجيش
الامريكي حدد هدف التدريبات باظهار
الاستعداد لدعم الشريك الفنلندي من خلال
نشر قوه قتاليه ذات مصداقيه في الجناح
الشمالي لحلف الناتو وسينضم الى التدريبات
في النرويج اكثر من عشره الاف جندي من
بريطانيا والدنمارك والمانيا وهولندا
والناروج
[موسيقى]
وتعليقا على زياره بايدن لكافه وصف وزير
الخارجيه روسيس زياره وحزمتها العسكريه
التي وعدت بها الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا
بانها اداء تمثيلي تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه جاءت بالتزامن مع تاكيد بايدن على
وقوف بلاده الى جانب اوكرانيا في التصدي
للقصف الروسي وتاكيده بان اوكرانيا لا
تزال حره ومستقله حيث اتهم الجيش الروسي
بارتكاب جرائم حرب واستهداف المدنيين في
اوكرانيا
الرئيس الروسي بلادي كان قد طلب من وزاره
الدفاع الاستعداد لاجراء تجارب نوويه
معلنا تعليق بلاده لمشاركتها في معاهده
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه ومؤكدا استمرار
موسكو في تطوير العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بوتينقال خلال كلمه امام
البرلمان بمناسبه مرور عام على الحرب ان
اوكرانيا لن تترك لروسيا اي خيار سوى
القيام بعمليه عسكريه وكشف الرئيس الروسي
عن ارسال ضمانات امنيه للولايات المتحده
ولحلف الناتو قبلت بالرفض حيث حمل بوتين
الدول الغربيه مسؤوليه ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
الصراع وحول طول امد الحرب قال الرئيس
الروسي ان الغرب اعد اوكرانيا لحرب طويله
الامد
ليس فقط في الولايات المتحده بل كذلك في
بريطانيا وفرنسا وجميعها موجهه ضد روسيا
يجب ان نضع ذلك في الاعتبار في الظرف
الراهن لذلك روسيا ستعلق مشاركتها في
معاهده الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه
واذا قامت الولايه المتحده باجراء تجارب
نوويه فنحن سنقوم بالمثل اي حديث عن
الاخلال بنظام الردع النووي غير صحيح
اما التعليق الامريكيه على تعليق موسكو
مشاركتها في معاهده ستارت فجاء عبر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي وصف القرار
الروسي بغير المسؤول وان الولايات المتحده
ستراقب بعنايه لترى ما تفعله موسكو بالفعل
اعلان روسيا تعليق مشاركتها امر مؤسف وغير
مسؤول سنراقب بعنايه لنرى ما تفعله روسيا
بالفعل وسنحرص بالطبع على ان نكون في وضع
مناسب لاني بلدنا وامن فلكائنا
بدوره عبر الامين العام لحلف الناتو
يانستولتنبرغ عن اسفه لقرار بوتين تعليق
مشاركه موسكو في معاهده الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه ستارت داعيا اياه
الى اعاده النظر في القرار وحمل السولتنبر
الرئيس الروسي بوتين مسؤوليه الحرب وتمسكه
بالتصعيد مشيرا الى ان خطابه يؤكد انه
يستعد لحرب اوسع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مراسله العربيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك حسين
ابرز ما جاء في خطاب الرئيس الامريكي
اليوم في بولندا في وارسو
اهلا بك ميسون بدا الرئيس الامريكي وكانه
يتوجه مباشره الى نظيره الروسي عندما قال
ان المتسلطين لا يفهمون سوى كلمه لا بوتين
سيخسر الحرب وستخرج اوكرانيا رابحه
الوحشيه لن تفوز اوكرانيا لن تكون ابدا
نصرا روسيا اضاف الرئيس الامريكي استطيع
ان اقول اليوم وبفخر ان دعمنا لاوكرانيا
ثابت لا يتزعزع كنا جميعا نخشى قبل عام
سقوطكير اكياف التي اتيت منها للتو تبدو
اليوم قويه وفخوره وحره اشار الى ان الدول
التي دعمت العدوان الروسي حسب تعبيره على
اوكرانيا في مجلس الامن وفي الامم المتحده
هي فقط اربع دول بينما وقفت ضد العدوان
الروسي في الامم المتحده واربعون
قال متوجها الى الذين يدافعون عن الحريه
عبر العالم بارككم الله وبارك قواتنا ذكر
كلمه حريه اكثر من عشرين مره مؤكدا ان
الفتره المقبله ستشهد عقوبات جديده
ستفردها الولايات المتحده بالاضافه الى
شركائها الاوروبيين على روسيا ميسون
بالنسبه كاتيا لخطاب بوتين يعني اليوم
ايضا تزامن مع خطاب بايدن سبقه واخذ خطاب
بوتين البعض اعتبر بان هذا الخطاب لم ياتي
بجديد لم يتحدث عن تكتيكات جديده او تغيير
في خطه هذه الحرب ما ابرز النقاط التي
تحدث عنها بوتين اليوم وكيف تلقف الشارع
الروسي هذا الخطاب
مرحبا بك ميسون بالفعل اليوم خطاب الرئيس
الروسي الذي طبعا كان موجه اولا الى
الداخل الروسي وتحدث بشكل كبير عن العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه التي بداتها موسكو منذ
نحو عام في اوكرانيا عن اسباب التي دفعت
روسيا الى بدء هذه العمليه العسكريه طبعا
تحدث بشكل موسع عن ان الغرب هو من دفع
روسيا الى بدء هذه العمليه العسكريه بسبب
طبعا
دعمه باوكرانيا الان وهو ما سيؤدي الى
اطاله مده العمليه العسكريه الروسيه طبعا
بالاضافه لذلك هو تحدث عن الوضع الاقتصادي
والتماسك الاقتصادي الروسي وهذه ايضا
رساله كانت موجهه للشارع وطمنت الشارع
الروسي والشعب الروسي الذي طبعا كما
تعلمين هو بسبب العقوبات المتتاليه التي
فرضت على موسكو بالتاكيد هناك شعور الخوف
من انهيار الاقتصاد الروسي في الايام او
في الوقت اللاحق لذلك هو اتى بالحديث عن
الاقتصاد وتماسك الاقتصاد وعن نسبه
البطاله التي تحدث عنها طبعا انخفضت
مقارنه بالفتره السابقه لطمانه المواطن
الروسي بان الوضع الاقتصادي لا يزال
متماسكا حتى الان اما الرساله طبعا التي
وجهها الى الخارج الروسي وبالدرجه الاولى
اولا تحدث عن تعليق معاهده العمل بها طبعا
دون الانسحاب كما شدد ايضا ان روسيا هي
فقط علقت العمل بهذه المعاهده تحدث ايضا
عن ان روسيا ستقوم في حال عادت الى معاهده
او استانفت العمل بها ستقوم اولا
بالنظر برغبه الاتحاد الاوروبي وتحديدا
فرنسا وبريطانيا في الذي اللتان عربه عن
رغبتهما بالانضمام الى هذه
المعاهده في حال طبعا الكشف عن حجم
الترسانه الترسانه الاستراتيجيه لديها
وعندها تكون موسكو قادره على العوده الى
معاهده ستارت وطبعا منذ قليل كان هناك
تصريح للخارجيه الروسيه تحدثت وعلقت على
معاهده ستارت التي علقتها موسكو قالت ان
روسيا
روسيا يعني هي سيكون هناك طريقه عوده في
حال كان هناك اراده واضحه من الجانب
الامريكي وتفهم وعدم اتخاذ خطوات لعدم
استئناف هذه المعاهده التي علقتها اليوم
موسكو ميسون زين اعود اليك بسؤال الاخير
هناك اجتماع سيعقد غدا بين الرئيس بايدن
والدول التسعه للجناح الشرقي الناتو هل
لدينا اي تفاصيل عن هذا الاجتماع واهميته
نعم ينظر الى هذا الاجتماع على انه اجتماع
يهدف الى تعزيز التحالف السياسي والعسكري
والامني والاقتصادي للولايات المتحده مع
دول الخاصره الشرقيه
اذا جاز التعبير هذه الدول هي بلغاريا
رومانيا هنغاريا وبولندا البلد المضيف
لهذا الاجتماع سيجدد الرئيس الامريكي
خلاله التاكيد على ان حلف الناتو سيحمي
الدول الاعضاء فيه والدول المتحالفه معه
قد يطلب منهم ايضا اعاده النظر في
سياساتهم لتنسجم اكثر مع مواجهه التحدي
الروسي ولكن ايضا التحدي الناجم عن القوه
المتصاعده للصين بولندا بالمناسبه ستطلب
من الولايات المتحده خلال هذه الزياره
لبايدن ان يجعل من وجود قواته في هذا
البلد اي في بولندا وجودا دائما وباعداد
اكبر الولايات المتحده كانت وعدت سابقا
بانها ستجعل من بولندا خلال هذا العام
مقرا دائما لقياده عسكريه امريكيه جديده
شكرا لك من وارسو حسين قنيبر العربيه كما
اشكر زميلتنا من موسكو كاتيا تعمي مراسله
العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
حضرت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
اذا تعرضت اوكرانيا للهزيمه وخلال مؤتمر
صحفي مع الرئيس الاوكراني
قالت ميلوني ان ايطاليا ستقدم كل
المساعدات لاوكرانيا لكنها استبعدت ارسال
مقاتلات ايطاليه كذلك اعلنت ميلوني عن ان
ايطاليا تحضر لمؤتمر لاعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا في شهر ابريل المقبل وهذه صوره
مباشره الان لهذا المؤتمر الذي يعقد في
هذه اللحظات ديلا
سانتقل الان مشاهدينا الى تطورات الوضع
الميداني حيث اتهم الرئيس الاوكراني روسيا
بقصف المدنيين بلا رحمه وذلك بعدما اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني مقتل سته مدنيين واصابه
اكثر من عشره اخرين في قصف روسي على خير
الى ان القوات الروسيه تقصف بقوه واستهدفت
مناطق سكنيه ومحطه نقل عام
اتهم رئيس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
وزير الدفاع الروسي ورئيس هيئه الاركان
العامه في البلاد بمحاوله تدمير قواته
الذي يلقب بطباخ بوتين نظرا لقربه السابق
من فلاديمير بوتين الرئيس الروسي اتهم
وزير الدفاع بحرمان مقاتلي مجموعته من
الذخائر معتبرا ان تلك الخطوه ترقى الى
الخيانه العظمى كما نقلت عنه وكاله رويترز
وجود معارضه مباشره ومستمره لقوات مجموعته
خطاب الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حمل
رسائل كثيره لعل ابرزها اشاره الى وجود
انقسام داخلي بوتين توعد بمطارده ومحاكمه
من سماهم بالخونه كل الذين اختاروا خيانه
روسيا يجب ان يحاسبوا امام القانون
في الان ذاته مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر وجه
اسلحته الكلاميه اتجاه وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويغو ورئيس الاركان متهما اياهما
بمحاوله تدمير قواته وحرمان مقاتلي
المجموعه من الذخائر فالخطوه ترقى الى
الخيانه العظمى يقول زعيم فاجنرالونه
[موسيقى]
حكايه الانقسامات في روسيا ليست وليده
اليوم وزير الدفاع
في اكثر الايام المستعره بعد بدايه الحرب
العام الماضي ولمده اسبوعين تقريبا قبل ان
يظهر من جديد حينها قيل ان اختلاف موقفه
مع رؤيه بوتين ابعده عن الساحه
القصه لا تنتهي هنا الرئيس الشيشاني
الموالي لموسكو رمضان قادروف سبق وفتح
النار ايضا على قاده الحرب الروس سبتمبر
الماضي بعد الحمله العسكريه المضاده من
الجانب الاوكراني وقتها طالب بتغيير
استراتيجيه الحرب احداث تطفو على السطح
رغم ان بوتين يلوح دائما بورقه التوحد
خلفه لكنه لم يستطع ان يخفي جبل
الانقسامات بلال البجدين العربيه
ومشاهدينا قبل ان نتابع نذكر بالاخبار
العاجله التي ترد على شاشه العربيه حسب
ولست تقول بان الولايات المتحده او
العقوبات الامريكيه على روسيا ستشمل هذه
المره مسؤولين في مناطق وايضا ستكون ايضا
هذه العقوبات منسقه مع عقوبات اوروبيه
وستشمل ايضا اسر مسؤولين سنتابع الان
بالنسبه للمناطيض العسكريه ذات العاكسات
حيله هي جديده تستخدمها روسيا في اوكرانيا
وقياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اكدت
وجودها في اجوائها لنتحدث عن هذه المناطيد
المناطيس ذات العاكسات هي تقنيه قديمه
لكنها فعاله جدا خلال الحروب لانها تدفع
بالدفاعات الجويه للعدو ان تكشف عن نفسها
وفق الخبراء ايضا هذه العاكسات هي هدف
مثالي من
الرادار الذي نتابعه هنا هي تضمن عوده
اشعه الرادار في الاتجاه المعاكس تماما ما
يعطي علامه واضحه على شاشه هذا الرادار
ايضا بماذا تستخدم هذه العكسات تستخدم
لفحص الرادار عن بعد وايضا كاهداف كاذبه
على سبيل المثال تم استخدام عاكسات بعيدا
عن الجسور في خرسون للتشويش على الصواريخ
المهاجمه ايضا خبراء يقولون ان الهدف
الاخر من اطلاق المناطيد ما هو الا زياده
على نظام الدفاع الجوي الذي ايضا طبعا
نظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني قبل اي هجوم
مكثف بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ ايضا ان
اسقاط مناطيد رخيصه بصواريخ غربيه باهظه
الثمن امر ايضا غير مربح من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه فهو مكلف الحيله الروسيه
باستخدام المناطيد ذات العاكسات ايضا نجحت
في اوكرانيا لانها دفعت بها الى استنفاذ
ذخيره انظمه الدفاع الجوي التابعه لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الامر الذي سيؤدي الى مشكلات
كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه في المستقبل
ودائما وفق الخبراء
[موسيقى]
متابعه ايضا للاوضاع الامنيه بالتطورات
الميدانيه ايضا من خركه ينضم الى احمد
العربيه ايضا حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه
اهلا بكما سابدا معك احمد بالنسبه
للتطورات الميدانيه اليوم كان هناك قصف في
خركاب هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على التفاصيل
وعلى المناطق ايضا التي شهدت اشتباكات
اليوم
نعم اهلا ميسون يعني بالفعل الظلام الذي
يظهر من خلفي هو الاثر الذي تركته الحرب
الروسيه بعد عام كامل ليس فقط في كثير من
المدن الاوكرانيه كان هناك بالفعل لقصف
على عدد من المناطق بالطبع ابرزها
منطقه كوبنسكي هذه المنطقه التي تم
استهدافها بصوره قويه اليوم فضلا عن منطقه
خرسون هذا القصف في خرسون اسفل عن مقتل
سته اشخاص واصابه العديد من المواطنين
الاوكران بالطبع بخموت التي تقع في مقاطعه
هي التي تشهد الاشتباكات الاقوى ما بين
الجيش الاوكراني وبين القوات الروسيه
ومجموعه
هناك تاكيد من قبل القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هنا بان
الجيش الروسي يريد الوصول والسيطره على
مخمود في اسرع وقت ممكن قبل حلول الذكرى
الاولى للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا يحاول
او يعني القياده العسكريه الروسيه تحاول
بشتى الطرق الحصول على بعض المكاسب خلال
هذه الايام القادمه ربما للرد على الوصول
المستمر والدعم المستمر الغربي
والزعماء الذين يصلون بصوره مستمره الى
اوكرانيا لدعم موقف رئيس هذا بالطبع يعني
يؤكد ايضا على ان ما يقوله المواطنون هنا
من ان ضروره ان يكون الدعم الذي تقدمه او
يقدمه الغرب حقيقه وواقعا ليس كما حدث قبل
ذلك لان لانهم يقولون والقياده او بعض
القيادات هنا في خير كيف تقول انه تم
وعدهم باكثر من 67 مليار دولار لكن ما
وصله هو تقريبا النصف هذا المبلغ والمدن
الاوكرانيه التي تتعرض لقصف بصوره مستمره
تحتاج للكثير من هذه المساعدات لاعاده
ترميم واعمار هذه المدن
اهلا بك ميسون طبعا هذه الذكرى
السلطه الاوكرانيه تعتقد انها لن تمر
بسلام وان
الاتحاد الروسي سوف يقوم بعمليه استهداف
واسعه واسعه النطاق على جميع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهم يقولون ايضا ان الروس
يحبون
المناسبات
للمتعلقه بهذه الحرب طبعا
يعتقدون ان الاستهداف لن يكون فقط يوم 24
وانما قد يبدا منذ الثاني والعشرين
يعتقدون ان من يوم الغد قد تبدا عمليه
استهداف لعدد من المدن كذلك يعني قامت
السلطات الامنيه والجيش بعدد من الاجراءات
هذه الاجراءات ليست متعلقه طبعا بالعاصمه
كيف ولكن هنالك اجراءات خاصه بك قائد
المنطقه العسكريه والقياده العسكريه في
كيف اعلن عن تدريبات التزامن مع هذه
الذكرى للقوات المشتركه المسؤوله من حمايه
كيف هذه التدريبات تبدا من اليوم وتستمر
حتى تمر الذكرى هذه التدريبات تبدا من
وحتى القوات في الجهه الشماليه لانهم
يقولون انهم لا يستبعدون ان يكون هنالك
عمليه محاوله اجتياح بري ولكن يقولون ان
هذا الامر ضعيف جدا ولكن سيكونون مستعدين
لذلك كذلك انظمه الدفاع الجويه في على
اهبه الاستعداد كذلك اليوم
قائد البحريه الاوكرانيه اعلنا تحديدا عن
الساحل الاوكراني في البحر الاسود منطقه
اوديستا قال اننا جاهزون تمام الجاهزيه
لاي عمليات استفزاز من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
اتحدث عن انظمه الدفاع الجوي المتوفره
لديهم لهذا الامر وكذلك عن البحريه
الاوكرانيه قال عندما بدات الحرب كانت
الفجوه كبيره بين القدرات العسكريه
للبحريه الروسيه وبين القدره العسكريه
للبحريه او الاوكرانيه ولكنها تغلصت الان
مع الدعم العسكري الذي حصلوا عليه من
الغرب لذلكم مستعدين ايضا هنالك اجراءات
تخص الحكم المحلي مثل توقف الدراسه بشكل
مباشر التحويل الى الشكل الافتراضي وهو
اون لاين
وسيظل الوضع على هذا الوضع حتى تمر هذه
الذكره شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
زميلنا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل كيف كما
اشكر احمد على كل هذه التفاصيل الميدانيه
منفذ العربيه شكرا لكم
الحرب في اوكرانيا غيرت 20 مفهوما واسلوب
حياه التداعيات التي طالت العالم نستعرض
ابرزها وفق تايمز لبريطانيه الحرب في
الشرق الاوروبي اعادت المخاوف من حرب
النوويه لاول مره منذ الثمانينيات ما دفع
الناتو الى استبعاد محاوله تطبيق منطقه
حظر جوي فوق اوكرانيا اما الامر الثاني
الذي تحدثت عنه الصحيفه هو الازمه
الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي ضربت المملكه
المتحده وهي الاولى منذ اربعه عقود بعد
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث شكل السفر
ايضا غيرته هذه الحرب فشركات الطيران
البريطانيه والاوروبيه مثلا التي تطير من
والى اسيا تاثرت ايضا واصبحت الرحلات
تستغرق وقتا اطول لانه لا يسمح لها
بالطيران عبر المجال الروسي
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
بتهمه الارهاب الى ان تحكموا على المانيا
من اصلان ايراني بالاعدام وبرلين تتوعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه هذا
المساء من ملف الزلزال الذي ضربت تركيا
وسوريا والذي تكرر يوم امس في هاتاي جنوب
تركيا وشعر به سكان سوريا ولبنان
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع تركي خلوا اكارن اكثر من
عشرين الف سوريين عادوا الى بلادهم منذ
وقوع زلزال جنوب تركيا في السادس من الشهر
الجاري وزير التركي في تصريحاته
قيامه بجوله تفقديه في المناطق المتضرره
من الزلزال بمدينه انطاكيا وجود اي حركه
لجوء من سوريا باتجاه بلاده مؤكدا ان هناك
حركه عوده للسوريين من تركيا الى بلادهم
وفي تداعيات الزلزال المدمر التي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا في السادس من فبراير الماضي
اعلن الرئيس التركي الجاري اعلن الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عنا اجماليه ضحايا
الزلزال تجاوزت 41 الفا وشدد اردوغان خلال
تفقده ولايه عثمانيه على ضروره محاسبه
المسؤولين عن الخسائر الضخمه في الارواح
جراء الزلزال
لما حسينا ان البنايه كلها عم تهز فينا كل
السكان البنايه نزلوا على الشوارع
وصار رعب وخوف يعني بكل السكان بكل
الاعزاز صارت تخاف ونزلت مضى حدا شايف
الوضع اذا ضلينا عم نشعر بالخوف وعم يصير
هزات ارتداديه او هيك شيء راح ندور على
خيام ماوى نقعد فيه ايواء لبن ما يهدى
الوضع ان شاء الله كل العالم صار تصرخ خوف
يعني
ورعب والعالم صارت تبكي وتصرخ ونزله وما
بيعرفوا كيف نزلوا والله يا خي كنا باركين
بامان الله
اصلي العشاء ما حسينا الا صارت بتروح
وتجينا غير طلعنا رقد والله نحن بالطابق
الارضي ماذا يعني
يعني شلون طلعنا ما بنعرف يعني صاير فوقنا
اربع طوارئ كمان يعني عم نخاف انه يصير
فينا مثل مثل العالم اللي راحت يا عيني
تحت الانقاذ
سنتحدث الان عن الهزات الارتداديه اتجاه
تصاعدي تتخذه هذه الهزات الارتداديه التي
اعاقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه اكثر
من سته الاف واربعين هزه ارتداديه ووصلت
قوه احداها لسته فاصل اربعه درجه اي
بمثابه زلزال اخر ايضا حقائق اضيفت الى
تحليلات تهويليه وتنبؤات بان هذه لذات هي
تمهيد لزلزال اكبر
واقوى لكن بدايه ما هي الهزات الارتداديه
وهل فعلا هناك زلزال اخر متوقع وهو اكثر
تدميرا وفق خبراء جيولوجيين الهزات
الارتداديه هي طبيعيه جدا بعد زلزال كبير
كالذي ضرب في السادس من فبراير فكلما كانت
الهزه الاساسيه قويه كلما تبعتها هازات
ارتداديه اكثر على مدن اطول ويمتد احيانا
لايام واسابيع وحتى الى اشهر عندما زلزال
قوي مشاهدينا يتحرك قسم كبير من الفالق
الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل
تحركه بعد الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى
طبيعتها وهو ما يسبب هذه الهزات
الارتداديه ايضا يلعب حجم الزلزال وايضا
ضخامته دورا بذلك فطول الكسر الذي تسبب به
زلزال تركيا في الارض يتراوح بين 300 الى
350 كيلومترا ما يستوجب وقتا اطول ليلتئم
الفالق كله ويؤكد خبراء ان بعض الهزات لم
تكن ارتداديه بل هزات مستقله حدثت على
فوالق اخرى نتيجه الضغط تسبب به الزلزال
الكبير على ما يحيط به من فوالق اما
التحذير من امكانيه وقوع زلزال اقوى
فاحتماليته ضعيفه وفق علماء بحكم عد
الاتصال الفوالق ولا سيما ان زلزال قوي
الذي ضرب قبل اسبوعين حرر القسم الاكبر من
الطاقه الضاغطه فيما القسم الاخر ينتقل من
مكان الى اخر ويحدث هذه الاهتزازات
[موسيقى]
ايضا مع هذه الزلازل هناك متلازمه السحق
او الهرس وهي كابوس يلاحق السوريين
الناجين من تحت الانقاض وهو ما حذر منه
الدفاع المدني شمال سوريا ما هي متلازمه
الهرس مشاهدينا هي حاله خطيره تنتج عن
الضغط الشديد والمطول على احد اعضاء الجسم
ومن الممكن ان تؤدي الى الموت في الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه الاولى لذلك يحتاج لرعايه
صحيه خاصه
ومتقدمه الاطباء ممن تواجدوا وعالجوا
النجين بزلزال تركيا وسوريا تحدثوا عن ان
اكثر المشاكل الصحيه التي تهدد حياه
الناجين من تحت الركام هي الاضرار
المباشره العظميه والعصبيه اضافه لتلك
التي ينتج عنها نزيف البطن او الاحشاء او
الرئه من اخطر تلك الامراض ايضا ما يعرف
بمت الهرس الذي يهدد حياه الناجين حيث من
يبقى تحت الانقاض اليومين او لثلاثه يكون
لديه اذيات هرسيه للاطراف او ضغط على
الاطراف بكسر او من دون كسر وكدمات ضاغطه
تسبب انقطاع الترويه الدمويه ينتج عنها
ماذا تجمع مواد سميه نتيجه تحطم العضلات
والانسجه على راسها
الدمويه للاطراف بعد تحرير المصاب والناجي
وتحرير الطرف تعود التربيه الدمويه لتنقل
معها المواد السميه الى الكليات وتقوم
ايضا بتعطيل عملها ويحدث بعد ذلك اضطراب
للشوارد في جسم الانسان وعلى راسها
البوتاسيوم الذي يعتبر ماده سلميه للقلب
قد تؤدي
لتوقفهم ايضا بسبب متلازمه الهرس يبقى
المصابون تحت المراقبه الطبيه حتى النسبه
السوائل في الجسم الى المعدل الطبيعي وهي
احد اهم الاسباب التي تؤدي الى وفاه
الناجين من تحت الركام خلال الاثنتين ساعه
الاولى بعد الانقاذ ماذا يوصل الاطباء
يوصوا دوما بان مصابين متلازمه الهرس هم
بحاجه الى كثير من جلسات غسيل الكلى لضبط
الكرياتينين وايضا اليوريا والبوتاسيوم
وقبل ذلك يصوم ببدء معالجه المصابين من
موقع الحادث وهذا مهم جدا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الي عبر سكايب من مدينه في ولايه
ميريلاند الدكتور حسن مخزومي رئيس وحده
العنايه المركزه دكتور مخزومي اهلا بك
معنا نحن الان استعرضنا ما هي متلازمه
الهرس ولكن نريد ان نشرح للناس بشكل مبسط
ما هي هذه المتلازمه التي تصيب الناس خاصه
في كوارث مثل الزلزال الذي اتبعناه في
تركيا وسوريا في الاسابيع الماضيه
مساء الخير
الخلايا العضليه
تتميز عن كافه بقيه خلايه الجسم بانه فيها
كميه عاليه جدا من البوتاسيوم
وكذلك فيها ماده المايكلوب
البوتاسيوم بالدم
يوصل نسبه اربعه مليجرام بالميه اربعه ونص
ملغ
البوتاسيوم في الخلايا العضليه
190 الى 200 مليجرام
ماذا يعني ذلك
عفوا ماذا يعني ذلك
ولكن نحن نريد الامور تكون ابسط من ذلك
نريد ان نريح الناس هل هي خطيره هذه
المتلازمه وهل تصيب مثلا فئه عمريه اكثر
من غيرها من التي تعرضت الى هذه الحوادث
ان كان قصف وسقوط مباني او كان زلازل
هي خطيره جدا طبعا خطورتها تكمن في
حجم
الضرر للعضلات يعني مثلا اذا شخص تعرض الى
طعن في السكين مهما كانت السكينه كبيره
قطعنا ما تاثر على اكثر من واحد او واحد
ونص بالمئه من عضلات الجسم
الكميات البوتاسيوم اللي تخرج مو ذات
اهميه ولكن اذا العمليه عمليه هرس وخاصه
اذا الطرف المهروس يكون في كميه كبيره من
العضلات مثل الساق او الفخذ
فالكميات البوتاسيوم كميات البايب اللي
تخرج هي كبيره جدا
ما مدى اهميه ان تتم المعالجه بمكان
الحادث قبل النقل الى المستشفى ما بدا
اهميه ذلك
الاهميه انه كل ما انت باركتي مفعول
البوتاسيوم على القلم ومفعول ما يقلبن على
الكليه ابكر كل ما
الاثر على هالاعضاء الاثنين يكون اقل يعني
اذا انتظرت مثلا مهما كان اكو اسعاف واكو
يعني اذا تاخرت ساعه ونص ساعتين لحد وصوله
المستشفى فيجوز بهالساعه ونص الكليه تنضرب
وتحتاجين غسل كليه لمده اشهر او كيف الحال
اذا الدكتور يعني وجدنا بانه اتم انقاذ
اشخاص بعد ثلاثه ثلاثه عشر يوما من تحت
الانقاذ برايك هل كلهم من المفروض ان
يكونوا مصابين بمتلازمه الهرس ام لا ضروره
لذلك لا لا الحقيقه اكو كثير اشياء تعتمد
يعني هوايه من اللي كانوا
ما كان عندهم ضغط على العضلات يعني كان
ممكن مثلا عندهم كسور او عندهم
بالراس ولكن اللي اللي
يصير عندهم المتلازمه هم الذين بقوا مده
العضلات عندهم مكبوسه وطحت ضغط وماكو حركه
عندهم يعني مثل ما يقولون ترابت محصورين
في منطقه صغيره ما يقدرون يتحركون وبعدين
احنا شوف هل متلازمه جدا اقل بالنساء من
الرجال لانه عاده النساء ما عندهم البنك
من وزن العضلات اللي الرجال عندهم اياه
شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات وهذا الشرح
كنت معي عبر سكايب من مدينه بالتيمور في
ولايه نوري لاند دكتور حسن مخزومي رئيس
وحده العنايه المركزه
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو شهرين على تشكيلها بوادي روح حفاظ
على خط اتصال بين حكومه نتانياهو والسلطه
الفلسطينيه بدات تظهر وفق موقع اكس يوسي
حيث اكد الموقع اجراء كبار مساعدي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي محادثات سريه مع
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس منذ شهرين
تقريبا واضاف الموقع والامريكي ان تحرك
يكتسي اهميه كبيره فهو دليل على المشاركه
المباشره رفيعه المستوى بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه والحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه
الجديده من اجل حل المشاكل على الارض كما
يركز على الجهود المبذوله لتهدئه التوترات
في الضفه الغربيه والعمل ايضا على صفقه
تمنع مواجهه فلسطينيه اسرائيليه في مجلس
الامن
[موسيقى]
تحركات ومحادثات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه سريه
يجريها كبار مساعدي رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو والرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس في محاوله لتهدئه
التوتر المتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه
بحسب تقرير نشره موقع اكسيوس فان هذه
المحادثات السريه انطلقت منذ شهرين وتعد
من بين اولى الادله على المشاركه المباشره
رفيعه المستوى بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجديده
التي
ركزت على الجهود المبذوله لتهدئه الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه حيث يتصاعد التوتر منذ عده
اشهر وايضا العمل على تسويه التفاهمات
التي ادت الى تعليق التصويت في مجلس الامن
الدولي ضد المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه والحفاظ ايضا على الاتصال
بين القاده من اجل حل المشاكل على ارض
الواقع وفق موقع اكسيوس الذي اشار الى انه
من غير الواضح اذا كان جميع قاده الاحزاب
في ائتلاف نتنياهو وبعضهم من اقصى اليمين
على علم بالمحادثات ومحتواها الرئيسي
ونقلا عن مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
كشف موقع اكسيوس بان الفلسطينيين طالبوا
اسرائيل بوقف التوغل في المدن الفلسطينيه
وبان اسرائيل اوضحت انها لا تريد ارسال
الجيش الى مدينتي جنين ونابلس بالضفه
الغربيه
من رام الله ينضم الى محمد هواش المحلل
السياسي استاذ محمد اهلا بكم معنا ما مدى
دقه هذه المعلومات الذي التي ذكرها موقع
اكسيوس
حتى الان يعني لا يوجد يعني اي تصريحات
فلسطينيه
تؤكد ذلك او تنفي ذلك وعلى الرغم ان يعني
فكره وجود قنوات اتصال بين الحكومتين
الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه هي فكره عاديه
وطبيعيه في كل دول العالم بما في ذلك
الدول التي لديها مشكلات وعداء وحروب تكون
هناك قنوات اتصال لحل مشاكل للطرفين مشاكل
على الارض وبالتالي يعني هذا جزء من من
محاولات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فتح قنوات سياسيه واتصال بين الطرفين
لتهدئه الاوضاع ومنع اي انفجار مستقبلي في
المنطقه خصوصا استاذ محمد على اي اساس
تبنى محاولات التهدئه هل هناك من معلومات
حول اطر معينه يتم الاعتماد عليها لقبول
الطرفين بها
نعم التهدئه تبدا من خلال يعني التزام
اسرائيل بمنع يعني منع الجيش الاسرائيلي
من دخول
المدن الفلسطينيه مناطق الف ومنع ايضا
يعني عمليات استيطان كبيره يعني كل
الاجراءات الاحاديه الاسرائيليه ان تتوقف
وان يتوقف ايضا يعني محاولات اسرائيل
هدم منازل الفلسطينيين في القدس وفي مناطق
الاغوار
الشماليه وفي مناطق الاغوار الجنوبيه اي
عمليات التطهير العرقي ان تتوقف وايضا ان
يتوقف الاستيطان وان تتوقف عمليات القتل
الميداني في في المدن الفلسطينيه وفي
الشوارع الفلسطينيه وان تتوقف اعتداءات
المستوطنين على على الفلسطينيين في
الطرقات وفي في محيط المدن وفي المناطق
الريفيه هذه هذه يعني
اسس بسيطه جدا وعندما تتوقف هذه الاشياء
حتى تخف الاوضاع ويمكن يمكن من خلال وقف
هذه العمليات يعني مرفوضه والمخالفه
للقانون الدولي والمخالفه لحقوق
الفلسطينيين وهي انتهاكات يوميه لحقوق
الفلسطينيه عندما تتوقف يمكن الحديث في اي
شيء يمكن الحديث في في وقف يعني هل هناك
من المال مثلا هل هناك من امال او ضمانات
مثلا من الولايات المتحده ان تقبل اسرائيل
بكل هذه المطالب التي حضرتك الان ذكرتها
وايضا هناك تساؤل يعني هل كل اعضاء تحالف
نتنياهو يعلمون بهذه المحادثات
هذه هذه نقطه جوهريه ست ميسون اعتقد بان
بان يعني مطلوب من اسرائيل ان تتوقف هذه
الاشياء وان لم تتوقف فلا معنى لاي
محادثات ولا معنى لاي وسطات ولا معنى لاي
يعني استقرار في المنطقه من دون من دون
وقف الانتهاكات اليوميه لحقوق الفلسطينيين
في القدس وفي الضفه الغربيه وفي قطاع غزه
وفي مناطق يعني المستهدفه بالتطهير العرقي
في الاغوار كل كل
التفاهمات وكل المحاولات الدبلوماسيه لا
معنى لها بما في ذلك بما في ذلك يعني
محاولات الضغط الامريكي على السلطه
الفلسطينيه بسحب يعني
مشروع القرار او بتراجع عن عن وضع مشروع
القرار
بالخط الازرق
القبول او يعني الموافقه على اصدار مجلس
الامن بيان يطالب اسرائيل ما تطالب به
السلطه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليين بمعنى
مطالبه مجلس الامن لاسرائيل بوقف
الاستيطان ووقف تشريع البؤر الاستيطانيه
وقف عمليات هدم المنازل وقف عمليات القتل
للفلسطينيين ووقف كل عمليات الاستيطان
واسرائيل وافقت من حيث المبدا على تاجيل
ذلك او قالت بانه لا توجد يعني خطط خلال
الاشهر المقبله وبالتالي هذه فتره اختبار
اذا كانت هناك جديه اسرائيليه لوقف هذه
العمليات فيمكن للفلسطينيه ان يناقشوا اي
شيء ولكن هناك شك كبير لدى الفلسطينيين
لدى الجمهور الفلسطيني ولدا الراي العام
الفلسطيني بان كل هذه محاولات اسرائيليه
يعني تجاوز الوضع والمازق ويعني المشكلات
العميقه التي تواجه الاسرائيليين في
المجتمع الدولي وفي اوساط الراي العام
الدولي
ايضا محاولات يعني اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف داخل الحكومه بسن تشريعات جديده
تلغي يعني فكره الحمايه للمواطنين
الاسرائيليين اولا وللمواطنين الفلسطينيين
ثانيا تمهيدا لضم الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي
هناك هناك مخاطر شديده جدا تكمن وراء يعني
مشاريع هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمنيه
ولا ثقه للفلسطينيين بهذه
المقابلات تقدمها للفلسطينيين ساعدنا فيك
استاذ محمد ولكن اعذرني انتهى وقت
المقابله اشكرك من رام الله محمد هواش
المحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وكاله ميزان التابعه للسلطه
القضائيه الايرانيه ان القضاء الايراني
اصدر حكم الاعدام بحق المواطن الالماني
الايراني جيم شيتشارد بتهمه الافساد في
الارض وتتهم ايران شرب مهدي الذي يملك
ايضا اقامه في الولايات المتحده بتزعم
جماعه مؤيده للملكيه متهمه بتنفيذ تفجير
دامن في ايران عام 2008
من جهتها قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
ان لينا حكم ايران بالاعدام على الايراني
الالماني جيم مهد غير مقبول على الاطلاق
واكدت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان تطبيق
ايران حكم الاعدام على شرمهد سيقابل برد
قوي
في التاسعه هذا المساء بعد قليل
الذكاء الاصطناعي يغير القواعد دعوات
دوليه لاقرار اليات للحد من خطوره تاثيره
السلبيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد او دعت السعوديه مليار
دولار في البنك المركزي اليمني مؤكده انه
ذلك ياتي لحرص المملكه ودعمها المتواصل
لمسانده الشعب اليمني تنمويا واقتصاديا
وذكر بيان نشرته وكاله الانباء السعوديه
ان هذه الخطوه تؤكد وقوف المملكه الدائم
مع اليمن حكومه وشعبا وانه من المؤمل ان
تسهم في تعزيز القدرات بمجال تنفيذ برنامج
الاصلاح الاقتصادي وجهودي بناء احتياطيات
لدى البنك المركزي اليمني لتمكينه من
تعزيز الاستقرار الاقتصادي
من جهته عبر الرئيس مجلس القياده اليمنيه
رشاد العليمي عن شكره للسعوديه بعد
ايداعها مليار دولار في حساب البنك
المركزي اليمني وقال ان السعوديه صاحبه
رؤيا مسؤوله تجاه اليمن والاطاله ساندت
اقتصاد اليمن وخففت من معاناه شعبه
ايضا نشاد الرئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد
الملك بالوديع السعوديه مؤكدا انها ستدعم
جميع مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه واضاف عبد
الملك في تصريحات للعربيه ان الوديعه
السعوديه ستسهم في تحقيق الاستقرار النقدي
واستدعم قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني
للوفاء بالتزاماته واشار ايضا الى ان
اليمن يواجه تحديات كبيره في ظل التهديدات
الارهابيه للميليشيات
[موسيقى]
شدد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
على ان الصناع عارضت بحزم بحزم الاتصالات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
مؤكدا على ان الهيكل الذي يتمسك به
المجتمع الدولي لن يهز بمبدا الصين
الواحده
لطالما عارضه الصين بحزم الاتصالات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
ومبيعاته الاسلحه الامريكيه لتايوان لن
يغير استفزاز السلطات الحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي لاستقلال تايوان حقيقه ان تايوان
جزء من الصين ولن يهز الهيكل الذي يتمسك
المجتمع الدولي بموجبه عالميا بمبدا صين
واحده
[موسيقى]
الى موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يعد سلاح
ذو حدين حقيقه مشاهدينا قاعده اثبتها
الروبوت التابع لشركه مايكروسوفت عندما
خرج عن السيطره وذلك بعد ان هدد بهندسه
فيروس قاتل واختراق اجهزه كمبيوتر وسرقه
رموز نوويه وصولا طبعا الى التفريق بين
الزوج وزوجته كما فعل مع مراسل شبكه نيوز
هذه الحادثه اثارت مخاوف الباحثين
والعلماء حول العالم وطبعا تخيفنا ايضا
هنا من المهم جدا الاضاءه على مخاطر
الذكاء الاصطناعي رغم اهميتها ما هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي وماذا يحمل هو يحمل
اثارا سلبيه لا بل كارثيه على الانسان
وايضا على حقوقه وفق تحذير مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان التي ابدت مخاوفها
من ان هذا التطور الذي تشهده اجهزه الذ
الاصطناعيه خصوصا لجهه عدم القدره على
التحكم بها او السيطره عليها ومع استمرار
وتيره ثوره التكنولوجيا تشير التقديرات
الى ان ملايين الموظفين والعمال سوف
يفقدون وظائفهم هذا فيما يخص العمل لكن
خبراء في الذكاء الاصطناعي في المجالين
الصناعي والاكاديمي حذروا ايضا من خلال
ورقه بحثيه من ان هذا القطاع سيؤثر سلبا
ايضا على الجنس البشري حقيقه كما شددوا
على ان الاستخدام المزدوج وقدره الاجهزه
التقنيه على اتخاذ القرارات المعقده في
الثانيه الواحده يمكن استخدامها في
النقدين اما لمنفعه الناس واما لايذائهم
اكثر من ذلك مشاهدينا الخطر الاكبر الذي
يهدد البشريه هو مصارعه الدول الكبرى الى
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل واسع
للاغراض العسكريه وهو ما تفعله خصوصا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه روسيا الصين
التي خصصت ميزانيات ضخمه لهذا الغرض كما
انها ترفض فرض حظر على هذه الاسلحه او
تقييد استخدامها وهنا يطرح التساؤل المخيف
هل من الممكن ان يسيطر علينا الذكاء
الاصطناعي ويتحكم بنا قريبا لنرى
[موسيقى]
نذكر بعناوين التاسعه هذا المساء
بالعداء تجاه روسيا
والرئيس الامريكي يردوا انت من تسبب
بالحرب
معاهده نيو ستارت النوويه تلفظ انفاسها
الاخيره بين نعي روسي وتوعد امريكي وتخوف
اممي
زلزال جديد ام هزرتديه الزلزال الاخير
فيها تايحير العلماء والمخاوف تدفع
السوريين للعوده الى بلادهم
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن دائما نتابع
الاخبار ما 360 واليوم مع طاهر سولو اليوم
طاهر سولو صحيح يعني شو اسبوعين لترجع
راويه من الرياض ان شاء الله نحن سنتابع
بالتفصيل خطابي بوتين وبايدن واصداء هذين
وردود الافعال عليهما في مختلف العواصم
اضافه الى موضوع الزلزال طبعا نتابعه بكل
تفاصيله ارجو ان تكوني معنا